hey guys it's Jan here Ryan Reynolds has
said that his Deadpool movie has more
Easter eggs than the Easter Bunny so I
put together every Easter egg a
reference I could find in this video I'm
sure you'll a spotted other cool ones
too so do share those in the comments
below and just before I kick off I've
got an awesome giveaway so if you'd like
a chance to win some cool Deadpool merch
make sure you subscribe and comments
about your favorite Easter Egg on this
video for more details and ways to enter
the comp check out the gleam link in the
video description below now a quick
reminder there will be spoilers ahead so
if you're not ready for that check out
my non-spoiler review of the movie here
first up the opening credits are
littered with some great mess of movie
jokes such as starring God's perfect
idiot and British villain the hot chick
a CGI character a good chooses cameo and
many more and floating among the credits
is a coffee cup labeled rob al in honor
of Deadpool comic book co-creator Rob
Liefeld there's also a nod to Ryan
Reynolds turn as Hal Jordan in the 2011
film Green Lantern with a Green Lantern
trading card popping out for wallet and
a copy of People magazine floats by with
Ryan Reynolds on the cover as of 2010
sexiest man of the year and Layton in
the movie Deadpool stuffs a sack of Hugh
Jackman 2008 sexiest Man of the Year
magazines into his gun bag and as you'd
expect there's a ton of comic book
references in the movie to the humor is
seen with pizza delivery guy Jeremy in
apartments owner mr. merchant is a
subplot that closely resembles a
storyline from the comics where Deadpool
was contracted to kill a pizza delivery
guy who'd spread a nasty rumor about a
girl in high school in the comics the
pizza guy is called Gavin whereas in the
movie Gavin is actually the first name
of the guy who owns the apartment given
this sequence involves two guys a pizza
and later a girl it's also a nod to ryan
reynolds breakout role as Michael Berg
Bergen in the TV comedy series two guys
a girl and a pizza place and Deadpool's
line what situation isn't improved by
pizza is another nod to the situation
comedy or sitcom that Reynolds made his
name in and studi notice that the pizza
box is from Feige pizzeria which is a
nice allusion to former x-men producer
and current Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige
later when wave meets the girl the pizza
I was talking he says he should have
brought his rollerblades which is a
callback to the comics where Deadpool
goes rollerblading Wade's mercenary bar
hangout is called sister Margaret's
school four-way with children which is
the same as Deadpool's mercenary hangout
in the comics which is also known as the
hell house Rob Liefeld Deadpool's
co-creator has a small cameo as one of
the patrons at weasels bar and when Wade
walks into the bar for the first time
you can hear the words [ __ ] Liefeld
which is likely an allusion to his
controversial status with some comic
book fans by the way Deadpool's costume
has a trademark Liefeld pouches and
booth one of the mercenaries at the bar
could be a nod to assassinate AKA andre
booth the cyborg killer from the comics
and the character of buck feels like
it's based on the character Steele
Fitzpatrick aka ACF who was also a
portly mercenary and friend of
Deadpool's at the Hell House in the
movie Wade Wilson chooses a name
Deadpool from the betting pool that
weasel runs on which mercenary will die
next a parallel to the comic book origin
story were Wade chooses his name from a
betting pool on which inmate would die
next the Weapon X government
experimentation facility one of the
other superhero names suggested by
weasel is scare devil a jibe at
daredevil who Deadpool has teamed up
with in the comics and the action scene
where Deadpool is fighting goons in a
corridor is reminiscent of a similar
scene in Marvel's daredevil on Netflix
which itself was a nod to a fight scene
in the movie old boy and by the way
Philip Silveira was the stunt
coordinator for both Deadpool and
Netflix's daredevil Wade also joked he
should be captain Deadpool which is both
a nod to Ryan Reynolds role as Captain
excellent in the movie paper man and
probably also a crack at Captain America
there's also a bit of a parody of
Captain America shield when Deadpool
throws a car wheel rim at Ajax when
they're on the highway talking about
names Deadpool jokes at Ajax his name
sounds surprisingly made up and that he
probably took it from the dish soap he
also wonders what Ajax his real name
might be in office Bruce and Scott as
possibilities which could be nod to the
Hulk's name Bruce Banner and Cyclops his
name Scott Summers or at man's name
Scott Lang Ajax is obsession with not
using his real name Francis is taken
from the Deadpool and death 1998 annual
in which Deadpool discovers at age
hates being called by his real name and
in a post Breaking Bad world Ajax is
often repeated line what's my name also
has a ring of Walter White's words say
my name about it the name tags that Wade
steals from Ajax as a surname Freeman on
it which is likely a nod to Marvel comic
book Inca Jeremy Freeman who inked an
issue of cable and Deadpool where Ajax
returns from the dead on waves TV screen
oh and by the way in the comics as in
the film Ajax explains how his nerve
endings have been scorched so he no
longer feels pain and because Fox have
the movie rights to Marvel's mutant
superheroes x-men a Marvel can't use the
word mutant in their movies Ajax s
description of his henchwoman angel dust
as inhumanly strong feels like a cheeky
nod to marbles in humans who are part of
the MCU and agents of shield and their
own upcoming movie when Wade gets a
Voltron defender of the universe ring
with its arcade tickets it's an easter
egg to the time in the comics when
Deadpool converted himself into Voltron
combining his supporting brute force
characters into one super robot and
there's another nod to this at the end
the movie when deadpool says to colossus
and negasonic teenage warhead for a
minute there it felt like we were three
mini lion robots coming together to form
one super robot the movie also has some
nice hints to Vanessa's copycat
alter-ego in the comics for example the
white streaks in her dark hair hint at
copycats whiter and because copycat has
blue skin in the comics we sometimes see
Vanessa with blue objects such as her
blue bedsheets and her transparent
umbrella which has a blue rim and a blue
handle when Vanessa says to Wayde Red's
your color it brings out the bloodshot
in your eyes at the nod to copycats
sometimes red eyes in the comics the the
funny Star Wars joke between Wayde and
Vanessa when she tells him to ride a
bitch's back like Yoda does Luke's and
note she's referencing the Empire
Strikes Back not the first Star Wars
movie and when Wade replies to her it's
like I made you in a computer is a cool
Easter Egg to x-men 2 when mystique is
searching through Strykers computer and
copycats name appears and in the trailer
Vanessa's lying I've played a lot of
roles in my life damsel in distress
ain't one of them is a reference to both
her shape-shifting powers as copycat in
the comics and also to Morena Baccarin
'he's multiple TV and film roles such as
Gotham Firefly serenity V and many more
and
the stripclub weather Nessa works Stanly
cameos as an emcee introducing the
strippers onstage with a line give it up
for chastity and we also hear Lee's
voice in the background at the club
saying you can't buy love but you can
rent it for three minutes when Wade
finds out about his cancer at the
oncologist is a nod to Deadpool's hatred
of clowns and the comics when he quips
to the doctor you're clowning not
clowning I sent clowns the BR 30 shirt
that Wade was at numerous points in the
film was a callback to the comics where
Deadpool as a fan of Golden Girls
actress Bea Arthur calling her the
sexiest woman alive
back at weasels bar Wade's joke that the
recruiters proposal sound like a dodgy
infomercial is a callback to the comics
where Deadpool mocks supervillain
taskmaster Owen when he calls the
recruiter Agent Smith it's a nice nod to
the matrix antagonist of the same name
and when Wade tells a recruiter that I
tried the hero business and it left a
mark
it's a dig at Ryan Reynolds role in the
critically panned Green Lantern movie
and earlier in the movie at the
skateboard park when Wade looks at his
greenroom sunglasses and disgust and
throws him away it feels like a jab at
the Green Lanterns mask later at Ajax's
workshop Ryan Reynolds pokes yet more
fun at the Green Lantern movie with
Waveline please don't make my suit green
or animated also at the workshop we get
a glimpse of the mutant mero who has
bones which grow out of her body
when Wade's in the glass oxygen
deprivation case he steals a match from
angel dust and lights it as a way to
escape which feels like a nod to Ryan
Reynolds movie buried where he's trapped
in a coffin with nothing but a lighter
and a cell phone to help him get out and
when Wade emerges from the rubble of the
workshop it feels reminiscent of the way
that dead pulls hand emerges from the
rubble and the post-credits of x-men
origins Wolverine speaking of that movie
the sideswipe at that version of
Deadpool when in this movie the Merc
with a mouth says shit's just gone
sideways in the most colossal way and
the camera immediately cuts to an action
figure of the origins Wolverine Deadpool
with its mouth sewn shut and the joke
continues as we hear Wade's say this is
my most prized possession but as the
camera pans up we realize he's actually
talking about one's make it big album
and there's another reference later to
that Deadpool when Ajax tells way to
shut up or heal so his pretty mouth shut
and also when waiters in the oxygen
deprivation tank and refuses to say a
Jackson's name we hear Deadpool's
voiceover say sorry Frances my lips are
sealed
by the way when Wade jokes that he looks
like he was bitten by a radioactive
shar-pei it's an easter egg to a very
similar moment in cable and Deadpool
number two which was published in 2004
and coincidentally seem to predict rhyme
men also play Deadpool there's also
several Spiderman references in the film
including the line go get a tiger which
weasel says to Wade and which Deadpool
also later says to negasonic teenage
warhead the lines and echo of Mary
Jane's words to Peter Parker go get him
tiger at the end of the spider-man 2
movie and when the action freezes
Deadpool midair we find him in a typical
upside-down spider-man pose spider
monkey from the alternate Marvel Apes
universe also gets a mention when
Deadpool's fighting two female opponents
and in Wade's final voiceover his
mention of your friendly neighborhood
poor guy is an obvious play on
spider-man's popular phrase your
friendly neighborhood spider-man
there's also street sign for Parker
Boulevard and a host of other street
signs and nods to the comic books or the
movie itself including Fabian Road and
nici Ezzor streets which are named after
Deadpool co-creator Fabian Nicieza
Miller streets named for director Tim
Miller or actor TJ Miller who plays
weasel and silver Avenue in Chatham
Circle and nods to Deadpool VFX
coordinator Scott Aaron silver and
tamesha Hamm there are also loads of
jokes and references to Fox's popular
mutant movie franchise x-men including a
glimpse of the x-jet when Colossus says
they're off to see Professor X Deadpool
asks McAvoy or Stewart these timelines
are so confusing
Deadpool's joke about only ever seeing
two x-men at the mansion and not being
able to afford more x-men characters is
a reference to this r-rated movies tight
budget compared to the budgets of many
pg-13 superhero movies and negasonic
teenage warhead pokes fun at the
franchise with jokes about matching
unitards and a house that blows up every
few years and Deadpool's tirade about
the neverland mansion in other words
it's saviors home for gifted youngsters
and Charles Xavier being a creepy
Heaven's Gate looking [ __ ] is a
nod to some of Professor X's less savory
moments in the con
for example when he admitted he was in
love with a 15 year old Jean Grey
when Colossus tells negasonic teenage
warhead that breakfast is the most
important meal of the day an officer a
protein bar is a callback to a candy
variant cover of Deadpool which features
a fake advertisement for a protein bar
Marvel issued the cover as a dig at
their rivals DC who'd been running half
page Twix ads in their comics by the way
that cover also shows Deadpool and rhino
fighting and was a Rhino Easter Egg and
weasels bar with a rhino head trophy on
one of the walls when comic book writer
Grant Morrison created negasonic teenage
warhead he named her after a song by
American rock band monster magnet in the
movie Deadpool thinks it's the coolest
name ever which is exactly what the
screenwriters thought too which is why
they included her in their script in the
comics warhead is a member of the
Hellfire Club and a student of telepath
Emma Frost whereas in the movie she's an
x-men trainee who at the junkyard later
in the film we see in her x-men uniform
and let's not forget the reference
Deadpool makes the x-man Hank McCoy when
he asks Colossus to tell beast to stop
[ __ ] on his lawn I just mentioned
the junkyard well when Deadpool arrives
there his line time to meet the chimi
[ __ ] chango's there's a cool nod to
the comics where he has a passion for
repeating the word chimichanga over and
over because he likes the way it sounds
as Deadpool warheads and Colossus ride
in to confront Ajax in his gang we hear
DMX is hip-hop track X gonna give it to
you which is a nice nun to the Weapon X
program which created Deadpool when
Deadpool removes his underwear to use as
a white flag in the junkyard scene it's
a nod to a similar moment in Deadpool
number 31 there's a great moment when
Deadpool's fighting one Ajax's men and
suddenly they stop and the other guys
revealed as Bob who Deadpool knows this
funny scene could be a nod to barber
Hydra agent to his numerous storylines
with Deadpool in the comics or given
that Deadpool mentions Jacksonville and
that the food Bob's wife makes is bad
for the waistline the character could be
a reference to Billy Bob Riley who grew
up in Jacksonville and whose alias is
fat spelt pH 18 in fact the character
fat actually appeared in x-men the last
stand
and when Ajax says to Deadpool I hear
you grow back body parts when I'm
finished
body parts are gonna have to grow back
you well it resembles a timing cable and
Deadpool if looks could kill
when Deadpool regenerates after being
turned in
nothing but a puddle and when Ajax
sticks a knife in Deadpool's head and he
starts to hear Chicago's you're the
inspiration it's a callback to cable and
Deadpool number 49 when kazar sticks a
knife through Deadpool's head while a
tune plays in the background and a final
showdown are what looks like a rusty old
Helicarrier and the post-credits joke
about samuel l.jackson showing up is a
poke at Marvel Cinematic Universe ok
let's talk about the 4th wall in the
comics Deadpool famously breaks the
fourth wall and the movie certainly
doesn't disappoint there's a moment
where Colossus tells Deadpool he can
hear him talking and Deadpool replies I
wasn't talking to you I was talking to
them which is a nice callback to a
similar moment in the comics between
Deadpool Benjamin Franklin and SHIELD
agent Emily Preston and there are loads
more examples such as when Deadpool
flicks chewingum on the camera lens
while in the taxi also any talks to the
audience saying oh hello I know right
whose balls did I have to fondle to get
my own movie rhymes with Paul Vereen and
let me tell you he's got a nice pair of
smooth criminals down under he adds in
his best or the accent of course it's
more gentle ribbing a few Jackman later
when Wade reveals a Hugh Jackman face
cut out and staple to his own face to
hide his scars from Vanessa and there's
even a fourth wall letter joke with
Deadpool pointing out a fourth wall
break within another fourth wall break a
nod to the time when Deadpool explained
the fourth wall to other comic
characters in the comic books at the
fourth wall breaks include Deadpool
saying cue the music and when he freezes
the action to explain why this is a
different kind of superhero movie and
there's an absolute barrage of
pop-culture references to for example
Deadpool has an adventure time watch and
a Hello Kitty duffel bag he jokes about
honey boo boo reality TV star mama June
he argues about the merits of different
IKEA furniture with blind al he has a
Deadpool toy on the Shelf in his
apartment as well as a Star Wars
lunchbox
annie pokes fun at Batman and Robin
saying that Robin loves Batman
and speaking of Batman when Wade wonders
of his mask is muffling his voice it's a
little jab at Tom Hardy's Bane in the
Dark Knight Rises when fellow bar patron
buck comments that he'd hid this in
reference to Vanessa she makes a Lord of
the Rings reference when she grabs his
balls and tells him to say the words fat
Gandalf and Wade tells Vanessa to hakuna
his Tatas making a Lion King reference
to the song Hakuna Matata
Wade's promised that he'll return and
boombox Careless Whisper outside
window is a nod to director Cameron
Crowe's first movie say anything where
John Cusack plays Peter Gabriel's in
your eyes outside his ex-girlfriend's
window there's several other musical
jokes in the movie - including nods to
new metal band limb biscuit the rock
band spin-doctors and of course more
mentions of Wham the second album make
it big which featured Careless Whisper
and deadpool also were the t-shirt from
the rock musical Rent oh and negasonic
teenage warhead shaven head leads
Deadpool to tell her nothing compares to
you and to call her Sinead after Irish
singer Sinead O'Connor who had a massive
hit with that song back in 1990 and he
also calls warhead Ripley from alien 3
after Sigourney Weaver's iconic
character in that movie there's also a
great joke about the taken franchise and
it starred Liam Neeson's parenting
skills and as a shout-out to the
Godfather when Deadpool turns over the
x-mansion and tells Colossus that I've
got an offer you can't refuse and in the
montage where Deadpool searching for
Francis the kill using a Zamboni ice
resurfacer is a nod to Austin Powers
Wiesel suggests that wage should start
making his own horror movies as his face
looks like The Nightmare on Elm Street
character Freddy Krueger [ __ ] a
topographical map of Utah there's also a
nod to the Marvel Comics Blade franchise
when Wiesel tells Ajax and angel dust to
enjoy their blade - midnight screening
which is interesting as Ryan Reynolds
has said it was his role as vampire
hunter Hannibal king and blade Trinity
which brought him to the attention of a
Fox executive who thought that character
and Deadpool had many similarities and
asked him to play the role the reference
to Danny Boyle's movie 127 hours when
Deadpool soars off his own hand was
brilliant
and just before he jumps onto the
garbage truck he also references author
Judy Blume's 1970 young adult novel are
you there God It's Me Margaret
also when deadpool introduces himself to
taxi driver to Pinder as pulled dead it
feels like a funny twist on James Bond's
classic line bond James Bond and he also
tells her pinda that director Ron
Howard's sci-fi movie cocoon about a
bunch of old people maybe end again by
an alien life force is pure pornography
when Deadpool and blind owl argue about
whether looks are important or not he
asks her what do I keep telling you mrs.
Magoo and not to the nearsighted cartoon
character mr. Magoo
and when blind owl says that looks onto
everything Deadpool keeps the
pop-culture and meta references flowing
with his
when sahn footballer David Beckham's
high-pitched voice and ads do you think
my medals got this far on his superior
acting method the various toy or
animated unicorns and rainbows Oaks that
we see are a reference to the popular
memes of Deadpool riding a unicorn or
Pegasus the final scene where Wade says
the Colossus I'm just a boy about to
stand in front of a girl and tell her
[ __ ] am I gonna tell her is a parody of
Notting Hill where Julia Roberts says to
Hugh Grant I'm also just a girl standing
in front of a boy asking him to love her
there's also a whole bunch of meta
moments in the movie for example right
at the start
Deadpool picks up a haunted Segway tours
leaflet looks at it thoughtfully and
then saves it in a suit this could be a
joke about the narrative structure of
the film and the way Deadpool plays
around segwaying between different times
and places throughout the movie Deadpool
pokes fun at the superhero genre in
general and shows how self-aware he is
for example he jokes about superhero
landings and how bad they are for your
knees and when he thinks of the pros and
cons of being a superhero he lists
lucrative film deals both origin stories
and larger ensemble team movies as a
positive Owen at the bar when weasel
tells Wade that the recruiter guy wants
to talk to him he adds it may further
the plot and later when Wade comes up
with his alias Deadpool weasel comments
that sounds like a [ __ ] franchise and
the animated unicorn which shits money
during the closing credits as the
producers names appear on the screen
it's a joke about them doing very well
for themselves out of these superhero
movies the post-credits scene where
Deadpool appears in his Ferris Bueller
style dressing gown and asked why are
you still here is a meta reference to
the popularity of post-credit scenes in
comic book movies especially Marvel
movies the look of the whole scene owes
a lot to director John Hughes film
Ferris Bueller's Day Off
from the layout of the room with its two
doors and the pictures on the wall to
the wallpaper and Reynolds even ends the
post-credits with chicka-chicka
from yellow song oh yeah which also
featured in the classic 80s comedy ok
guys what other Easter eggs and
references did you spot in Deadpool and
what was your favorite moment in the
movie I can't wait to read your comments
below and if you want to check out more
of my Deadpool videos I've got links to
my playlist here including 10 things you
didn't know about Deadpool and my review
of the movie and don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment
your favorite Easter egg on this video
for a chance to win some awesome
Deadpool merch for more details and ways
to enter the comp check out the gleam
link in the video description below
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers